so many independent filmmakers only get
a chance to make one feature film which
is so true usually they're tapped out
financially usually you've been
fortunate to do so many what do you
attribute that to
I don't know low budgets compel I don't
know I think it now's a good time to be
a filmmaker you know technology's
helping you can keep the budgets low and
get your films made you know that's good
but I think what's good about the
current media environment you really can
make a film and see if it's what you're
meant to be doing you know I always felt
really comfortable making films that's
how I think that's what I think about
that's who I am you know but writing a
novel would be tougher for me it's not
my mentality you know so some people I
think they want to make films they make
one you realize um you know maybe that's
not my medium so it's just finding your
right medium I was lucky to fairly early
on hit on it that's just the terms I
think in but you know the industry
changes a lot but the the core mission
of most filmmakers who just tell stories
that are meaningful to them that that
never changes